مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوي
[تصفيق]
الجيش السوداني
بعد ثمانيه اعوام السعوديه تكشف عن
تعدادها الجديد 32 مليون مواطن ومقيم
وشباب يتصدرون تعداد السعوديين الحديد
يشكلون ثلاثه وستين في المئه من اجمالي
المواطنين ذكورا واناثا
في الرابعه
رايد الفضاء ريان وعلي يصلانه هيوستن بعد
عوده سالمه الى الارض
واخضعان لحجم صحي
ت تترقب احتفاء تاريخيا الليله الاتحاد
يجدد عهده بالمنصات عبر لقب الدوري
نبدا من السودان الذي لا يزال تحت وطاه
صراع مسلح لا ينتهي مراسل العربيه فاذا
بتجدد القصف المدفعي في شمال ام درمان
بالخرطوم وعلى صعيد جهود التسويه علق
الجيش السوداني مشاركته في مفاوضات جده
ذكرت مراسله العربيه نجيش السوداني ابلغ
بان قوات الدعم السريعه لم تلتزم ببنود
الاذن وانه لا معنى للاستمرار في تمديدها
في ظل الخروقات التي ترتكبها قوات الدعم
السريع واكدت مراسله العربيه ان الجيش
السوداني علق مشاركته في مفاوضات جده ولم
ينسحب منها
هذا مراسل العربيه باغلاق الكبر الفتيحاب
من جهه ام درمان بالخرطوم اضافه ان
الطيران الحربي عاود التحليق في سماء ام
درمان بالتزامن مع سماع دوي اطلاق نار
متقطع في منطقه المهندسين
مساحه المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
متوسعه الى مناطق خارج العاصمه حيث نشر
الجيش السوداني مقطعا مصورا لقواته من
مدينه الابيض في ولايه شمال كردفان واكد
انه تصدى لهجوم من قوات الدعم السريع على
المدينه وكبدها خسائر فاتحه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه اليوم عن
تعداد السكاني في البلاد الذي بلغ اثنين
وثلاثين مليون و 200 الف نسمه واضافت هيئه
الاحصاء بان تعداد السعوديين الذين تقل
اعمارهم عن 30 عاما مثل ما يصل الى 63% في
وقت مثل فيه السكان غير المواطنين نسبه
41% من اجمالي السكان اي تحديدا ما يزيد
انت لا تتعاشر مليون نسمه
الزميل لا يشاهد المتروك تعرفون اكثر على
ابرز الارقام في تعداد السعوديه 2023
ثمانيه اعوام عن اخر احصاء رسمي لسكان
السعوديه اليوم كشفت اعداد الحديث عن 32
مليون و200 الف نسمه يسكنون مناطق المملكه
وبنسبه نمو عن تعداد العام 2010 بلغت اكثر
من
34% منهم ثمانيه ملايين الف نسمه في منطقه
الرياض وحدها يشكلون سته وعشرين في المئه
من اجمالي السكان بينما جاءت مكه المكرمه
ثانيه باربعه وعشرين في المئه ثم المنطقه
الشرقيه ثالثه بنحو 16% من السكان مواطنين
ومقيمين رقم كبير سجل للسكان الاجانب في
السعوديه وفقا للاحصائيه الرسميه الصادره
عن الهيئه العامه للاحصاء حيث بلغت
اعدادهم ثلاثه عشره مليون و400
مقيم يمثلون 41% من اجمالي السكان الذكور
اكثر عددا من الاناث هذا ما كشفه تعداد
السعوديه عشرين ثلاثه وعشرين حيث بلغت
اعداد الذكور تسعه عشر مليون وسبعمائه الف
نسمه فيما بلغت اعداد الاناث اثني عشر
مليون وخمسمائه الف انثى ماذا عن فئه
الشباب السعوديين تحديدا كم يمثلون من
اجمالي سكان المناطق السعوديه هيئه
الاحصاء كشفت ان الشباب السعوديين الذين
تقل اعمارهم عن 30 عاما يمثلون ثلاثه
وستين في المئه من اجمالي عدد السعوديين
اما متوسط اعمار السعوديين ذكورا واناثا
جاء عند 25 سنه ما يؤكد اننا نعيش في
مجتمع غالبيته من الشباب
الدوسري سيد فاقد حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه مبروك اولا يعني انجاز النتائج
الاخيره في الاحصاء 20 23 لكن ما الذي
تغير في الارقام من 2010 حتى
شكرا على الاستضافه وسعيد يكون معكم اليوم
وانت تزال الفرصه هذه لتقدم بجزيل الشكر
والعرفاني لمولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
ولي عهده الامين على دعمهم المستمر لانجاح
تعداد السعوديه عشرين 22 وكذلك الجهات
الحكوميه والقطاع الخاص اللي ساهموا بشكل
كبير في نجاح التعداد ولا يفوتني ايضا
المواطنين والمقيمين ولا الذين ساهموا في
رفع دقه المعلومات وايضا المشاركه الفاعله
التعداد عشرين اثنين وعشرين بكل فخر اقول
انه من اكثر التعدادات في المملكه شموليه
ودقه في البيانات وهذه جدا مهمه تم
استخدام التقنيات الحديثه لضمان رفع دقه
العمل وايضا لضمان درجه الشموليه بالنسبه
للارقام وكما ذكر التقرير فيه نمو جدا
ممتاز صحي من 2010 الى الان طبعا التعداد
اخر تعداد حدث في المملكه كان في الفين
وعشره التعداد هذا 2022 استخدم باستخدام
التقنيات استخدم كاساس وبناء عليه تم
اعاده تقدير
التقديرات السابقه دائما بين التعدادين
يتم تقدير السكان بناء على مؤشرات التعداد
هذا تم استخدام البيانات السجليه واللي
ساهمت بشكل كبير برفع درجه التقدير النمو
اللي حصل
في السعوديين من 14 مليون الى
18.8 بالاضافه الى النمو العام
بنسبه 34% نمو السعوديين كمتوسط كان اثنين
فاصله خمسه في المئه لو نقارن السنه
الماضيه
السعوديين ز ادوا او التعداد او عدد
السكان زاد بمليون فاصله اربعه
فهذه فيها زياده جيده وطبعا
ودي اركز ايضا انه ما تم نشره في السابق
تم اعاده نشره الان بالتقديرات الجديده
التقدير اعداد السكان وليش قررتم انتم
ايضا في الهيئه
يعني مراجعه التقديرات السكريه السابقه
هذه الممارسه ويمكن قبل ما اعلق عليها في
اثناء عملنا في التعداد
تم تطبيق افضل ممارسات الدوليه وايضا
استعانه بخبراء متخصصين في التعدادات بشكل
عام في احد الخبراء يعني عمل على 14 تعداد
في السابق في المنهجيه هذه ما تعتبر جديده
كثير من الدول لما يصدرون تعداد جديد يتم
مراجعه التعداد السابق اللي هو 2010 ومن
ثم يتم اعاده تقديرات التعدادات مثل ما
ذكرت تعداد 20 22 المميز فيه ان نستخدم
تعدد مصادر البيانات هذه واحده وايضا
التقنيات الحديثه التقنيات الحديثه اللي
ساعدتنا مثلا في رفع تغطيه المساكن بشكل
كبير استخدمنا صور الاقمار الصناعيه لاول
مره استخدمنا عدد من البيانات السجليه
لاول مره العد الذاتي كان احد الادوات
اللي تم استخدامها بالاضافه الى
طرق التحليل وضمان دقه المعلومات في
الممارسه هذه يعني يمكن يعطيك عدد من
الدول اللي ايضا تعرفنا على تجربتهم
الولايات الامريكيه المتحده بريطانيا
اليابان استراليا وامريكا
الكوريا الجنوبيه كذلك
باستخدام هذه التقنيات والابتكارات هل
تعني بان التعدادات السابقه كانت غير
دقيقه سيد فهد
منذ اطلاق رؤيه 2030
وملاحظ عند الجميع التقدم التقني وايضا
الابتكار اللي حصل في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التقنيه اللي موجوده اليوم
ساعدتنا وبشكل كبير الى تفعيل اكثر
لاستخدام البيانات السجليه كمؤشرات اضافيه
ما كانت موجوده في السابق وهذه الفرصه
اعطتنا ايضا فرصه ان احنا نعود للسابق
لانه اي قرارات اي تخطيط من قبل الحكومه
الجهات الحكوميه او القطاع الخاص القطاع
الخاص لابد انها تبنى ايضا على سلسله
زمنيه
فقررنا ان احنا نعود الى 2010 نستخدم
البيانات السجليه اللي موجوده التقنيات
اللي موجوده لاعاده تقديرها عوضا عن
التقدير بشكل احصائي الان التقدير مبني
وبشكل مباشر ويعطينا صوره اقرب
للرقم اللي موجود المملكه وبالتالي السؤال
كان هل كانت غير دقيقه او لا لانه مثلا
احدهم يقول يعني في تعليقه على على نشركم
لنتائج ان التعداد لاول مره يكون التقني
لذلك السابق غير دقيق احدهم يعني استشهد
بتغريده كانت على صفحتكم في الايه
السعوديه للاحصاء مره قبل
بنجمال عدد سكان السعوديه في ذلك الوقت 31
واجمالي عدد سكان السعوديه منهم عشرين
اكثر من 20 مليون نسمه بمعدل
1.62% حتى نفهم بس شو اللي حصل
يعني ابي اركز مره اخرى اعاده تقدير
البيانات السابقه والتعداد السابق هذه
ممارسه دوليه مو بشيء جديد يعني ما يعتبر
شيء جديد في المملكه فهذا ممارس بشكل كامل
النقطه اللي بيركز عليها الاساس دائما في
التعداد العمل الميداني وبعدها يتم عمل
تقديرات بناء على مؤشرات اضافيه فاللي
موجود الان عندنا ما كان موجود في السابق
اللي هو التقنيات تعطيك صوره اوضح وصوره
افضل ودقه عاليه يعني انا بعطيك مثال على
الدقه اللي تم الحصول عليها عملنا بعد ما
انتهينا من جميع مراحل التعداد عملنا
مليون مكالمه
لاختبار الجوده وحصلنا على نسبه 95% وهذه
نسبه جدا عاليه ما ممكن انها تتحقق
ومقارنه بالدول في العالم الوصول لها مهوب
سهل لكن مع
مع العلم ان حنا وصلنا لها الحمد لله بسبب
التقنيات التقنيه هذه غير موجوده في
السابق فهي المنهجيه يعني هي اللي تعتمد
على الادوات اللي موجوده في في نفس
الوقت التعداد اللي حنا عملناه في 2022
اخذناك سنه اساس كبيسلاين وبعدين بدانا
نقدر لانه بين 2010 و2022 جميع السنوات
يتم تقديرها بناء على بيانات 2010 فلابد
ان احنا نعود الى 2010 نعيد له حساب العدد
السكان في حينه ومن ثم يتم تقدير باقي
السنوات بين الاثنين
تكلمت عن انه استخدمتم تقنيات وابتكارات
لاول مره سريعا ما هي هذه ما هي ابرز هذه
الابتكارات والتقنيه
في جميع المراحل يمكن اول مرحله كانت
التخطيط التعداد واستخدم الاقمار صور
الاقمار الصناعيه لتحديد المنازل او
المساكن الخارج القرى والمدن هذه كانت
يمكن في ذيك المرحله المرحله العد كان
العد الذاتي لاول مره يتم استخدامه وايضا
في التحليل وجوده العمل عملنا يمكن 200
مؤشر عن طريق الانظمه للتحقق من وجود
اخطاء او غيره لكن يمكن النقل الكبيره
وهذه اللي انا علمتها في المؤتمر الصحفي
الخرائط التفاعليه الخرائط التفاعليه راح
تتيح للقطاع الخاص القطاع الحكومي
والباحثين خريطه للمملكه يمكن
لاي شخص انه يعني يوصل لها على الطريق
الموقع وايضا يبحث عن كل مثلا مربع في
مربع جغرافي او حي في الرياض او في اي
مدينه اخرى ويحصل على التركيبه السكانيه
هذه يعني راح تدعم القطاع الخاص على سبيل
المثال عند فتح مشاريع جديده او التعرف
على التركيبه السكانيه في الاحياء او في
المدن وهذه كلها متوفره وبشكل
مباشر عن طريق الموقع
شكرا جزيلا لك من الرياض رئيس الهيئه
العامه للاحصاء في هذه الدوسري
هذا وقد اكد وزير الاقتصاد والتخطيط
السعودي فيصل ابراهيم من نمو الانشطه غير
النفطيه في السعوديه خلال الربع الاول من
2023 الجاري بلغ اكثر من 5%
هذا الاداء القوي اضافه الى ما اظهرته
والتقديرات السريعه لنمو الانشطه غير
النفطيه في الربع الاول لعام 2020 23
بنسبه 5.8 يؤكد متانه اقتصاد المملكه
وقدرته على الاستمرار في النمو مستقبلا من
خلال رفع مستوى الانتاجيه والتنافسيه
والابتكار في كافه الانشطه الاقتصاديه
وزياده مساهمه العديد من القطاعات وابرزها
القطاعات القابله للتصدير كالصناعات
التحويليه المتقدمه وصناعه السيارات
والسفن والنقل والخدمات اللوجستيه
بالاضافه الى القطاعات الواعده كالثقافه
والترفيه والرياضه والسياحه
من رياض ينضم الينا العضو المنتدى برئيس
التنفيذي لشركه رسائنا عبد الله سيد عبد
الله حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
استمعت الى الارقام
دائما هناك علاقه بين النمو السكاني
والارقام وبين الاقتصاد في ضوء هذه
الارقام كيف شايف
التاثير بين طرفين
مساء الخير اخوي خالد طبعا
كل تاكيد عدد السكان يمثل قوه اقتصاديه
يمثل قوه شرائيه يمثل سوق في نهايه الامر
في المعايير الاقتصاديه مهم جدا التقديرات
العدد السكاني التقدير القوه الشرائيه
تقدير هذا السوق في نهايه الامر ولذلك
يعني اليوم السعوديه كسوق ليست مثل اسواق
مثلا دول اخرى مجاوره بسبب طبعا عدد
السكان الكبير لذلك من المهم ملاحظه
ومتابعه نمو عدد السكان التركيبه السكانيه
كيف جايه
فهذه الامور تحظى باهتمام كثير سواء من
المستثمرين دخول فتح مشاريع جديده
منتجات جديده لابد ان يراعوا فيها
وينتبهوا وكذلك
ياخذ في العثمان عدد السكان ونمو السكاني
فلذلك اليوم يعني ابارك للجميع
والقياده بظهور هذه النتائج اللي طبعا
احنا زي ما نعرف نتكلم الاخوان والمسؤولين
عنها انها الاكثر شموليه والاكثر دقه وهذه
يعني لازم نحطها اكثر من خط لانها تعني
الكثير خلينا نبدا بالاستعراض بعض الارقام
اللي نشوفها لنا على الشاشه مثلا توزيع
السكان على مناطق السعوديه الرياض هي
الاكبر 26.7 من العشره مكه المكرمه في
المرتبه الثانيه المنطقه الشرقيه
15.9 بقيه المدن 32 ونص
هذه كيف ينضلها ايضا من ناحيه اقتصاديه
طبعا نرجع مره ثانيه هذا التكتل السكاني
او توزيع
الجغرافي للسكان مهم جدا في الاسواق يعني
اليوم بالنسبه لكثير من الانشطه
الاقتصاديه راح تفضل ان تكون مع تجمعات
السكانيه الكبيره الرياض واحده من اهم
الوجهات بالنسبه للشركات والاستثمارات
وهذا ما نراه على الواقع بسبب النمو
السكاني الحالي والنمو السكاني متوقع وهذا
شيء يعني سبق ذكره البقيه المناطق كذلك
منطقه مكه المكرمه هي المركز الثاني ولذلك
نلقى فيها تركز قطاعات وانشطه اقتصاديه
موجوده فيها وبالنسبه للشرقيه فهذا
التوزيع يعتبر الجيد يعني اليوم لما تفتح
انت المجال الاستثمار او النشاط اقتصادي
ما راح تفتحه يعني في منطقه نائيه او
منطقه عدد سكانها كلهم خمسين الف وستين
الف
بينما يكون عندك الفرصه انك تفتحه في عدد
سكان تجاوز الثمانيه مليون زي الرياض حسب
التعداد بالفئات العمريه الشباب 63%
بقيه الفئات 37% هذا هذا هل يمثل نقطه
تحول
على المدى القصير القادم او الطويل في في
في عجله الاقتصاد في المملكه السيد عبد
الله
بكل تاكيد يعني هذا تقريبا اهم رقم ممكن
تقراه في هذا الموضوع اول شيء ايش المعاني
الاقتصاديه اليوم لما تقول متوسطه اعماره
سكان السعوديه مثلا 25 سنه متوسط اعمار
السكان السعوديه بما فيهم المقيمين 29 سنه
و ايش معنى هذا المعنى هذا رقمه اول شيء
يدلك يعني انه اليوم
الطبقه
الشابه في المجتمع هي الاغلب زي ما ذكرت
وستين بالمئه هي تحت الثلاثين سنه وش معنى
هذا الكلام هذا معناه الكلام انه اليوم
هذه الطبقه هي الاكثر استهلاكيه احنا نعرف
كل واحد ما تقدم في العمر تنخفض عنده مثلا
الحاجه الاستهلاكيه بانها ترتفع عنده مثلا
خدمات الصحيه لا اثنين الوجود المتوسط
اعمار 25 سنه هذا معناه انه الطلب على
المساكن والعقار حيكون مرتفع الى عقود من
الزمن قدامنا
الثلاثه بالنسبه للتوظيف بالنسبه للخريجين
خلق الوظائف هذه كذلك في محور رئيسي على
الاقتصاد لانه اليوم انت لما تفتح اعمال
وانشطه تجاريه وتحتاج الى توظيف اليوم انا
اقول لك متوسط اعمار السكان 25 سنه فمعناه
انه اليوم فرص التوظيف او فرص انك انت
تلقى خريجين يقدرون ينظمون لسوق العمل
فرصه كبيره وهذه اذا خصوصا اذا كانت ترافق
مع تعليم عالي وتعليم يعني متوافق مع
انشطه مع الانشطه الاقتصاديه هذا كله يعطي
قوه وتحفيز ويعطي زياده جاذبيه للسوق
السعودي وديناميكيه حقت السكان
طيب الان عندنا
صح 63% شباب لكن اعتقد الارقام كمان تكشف
عن انه في معدل مواليد يتناقص
السيد عبد الله واعتقد كمان في نسبه طلاق
مرتفعه يمكن نتكلموا عن تكلمنا عنها في في
في فترات سابق
هذا ما يخلينا ممكن نخاف او نواجه في
مستقبلا شبح
تباطؤ النمو السكاني اللي بيكون له اثر
سلبي ربما على الاقتصاد وعجله التنميه او
انه ما في علاقه
يعني انا من مختص في في علم الاجتماع او
ممكن اللي يعطيك لكن كل تاكيد
التراجع في في عدد المواليد ونسبه
المواليد الاسره هذا في تراجع كبير في
الستينات والسبعينات اذا ما خاب ظني كانت
الارقام قريبه من ثمانيه للمراه مواليد
ثمانيه مواليد للمراه في اول الالفيه نزل
الى حدود الاربعه ثلاثه وشوي اليوم احنا
في تناقص ونزوري الى 2.2 عموما ما زلنا في
مستوى مطمئن من ناحيه النمو السكان لعقدين
من الزمن يعني اعتقد من عشرين الى ثلاثين
سنه على على المعدل الموجود اثنين فاصله
اثنين يعتبر جيد
الضمان نمو السكاني اكثر من 23 30 سنه
اعتقد انه راح يكون في مشكله اذا استمر
عندنا النزول من اثنين فاصله اثنين الى
اثنين فاصله واحد اثنين هذا راح مشكله على
مدى زمني اطول طبعا على خمسين سنه
على مدى الزمنيه نعم اقدر اقول لك عشرين
سنه لا يوجد خوف اكثر من كذا نعم يوجد
مشكله الاجانب حسب الاحصائيات هذه
41.6% في زياده في عدد الاجانب سكان
السعوديه في 2023 لكن هذه الزياده جاءت
بناء على ايش من هم هؤلاء الاجانب ما هي
مواصفاتهم ايضا الى اي مدى يساهمون ايضا
في تحريك عجله النمو الاقتصادي يتكلم عن
عماله
بمعدلات دخل
النازله يعني او نتكلم مع الناس بخبرات
بكفاءات مختلفه لهم اثر او نتكلم عن
مستثمرين
جميل جدا اول شيء احنا لازم نعرف نمو عدد
سكان سواء كان من السعوديين او غير
سعوديين
بشكل عام بعدين نفصل بشكل عام ينظله
ايجابي
ليش ايجابي لانه اليوم انت تنمو في عدد
السكان في نفس الوقت اقتصادك ين فاليوم
الاقتصاد مثلا اذا جينا واخذنا مثلا ارقام
مقارنه اخر تعداد سكاني كان في 2010 2010
عدد الاجانب اقل من العشره مليون بقليل
لكن كم كان حجم الناتج المحلي في ذلك
الوقت كان اقل بكثير من اليوم اللي وصلنا
وصلنا اليه نعم التغير
نمو سياسه الاقتصاد ربما بدل ما كنا
معتمدين على مجتمع على اقتصاد ريعي في في
كثير من شؤون اليوم تغير في تنويع في
الاقتصاد وتحريك في العجله فيها اكثر من
مجال هذا جيد
ملاحظه عليه لكن نمو الاقتصاد من 2010 الى
يتطلب نمو سوق عمل يتطلب زياده سكانيه
يتطلب الى سوق يستوعب هذا الانتاج
فبالتالي من الطبيعي جدا بل هو المطلوب ان
ينمو عدد السكان بشكل يتناسب مع النمو هذا
اثنين لابد ان يكون النمو هذا جاي من
جانبين نمو السعوديين نفسهم والمواطنين
ونمو من عدد الاجانب لابد يكون في شلون ما
فهمت انه لا بد يكون ايش نسبه النمو
متقاربه ولا شلون ما فهمت انه انت تتكلم
عن 41% والمستهدف في 2030 نتكلم من 50 الى
60 مليون صح ولا لا
نتكلم مثلا في 2010
الناتج المحلي وخلنا نفترض انه كان بحدود
تريليون ويمكن حاجه ما تذكر الارقام بشكل
مضبوط لكن ازود من شوي اليوم احنا نتكلم
على تلفون دولار
يعني نتكلم على ثلاثه فاصله 75 750 مليار
النمو ثلاث اضعاف نمو في حجمه في 2010
النمو عدد السكان من 2010 الى
2022 كان تقريبا 45 يمكن كذا
فانت تتكلم على النمو سكاني ومع نمو ناتج
محلي النمو هذا ما جاء من فراغ النمو
الاقتصادي لا بد من وظائف لابد من الناس
تعتجز بس هذول وين بتروح وين بتروح فلوسهم
والله انا المخرج والرايس تحرير يعني
يحاول يقنعوني قدر الامكان على اساس الوقت
وين بتروح الفلوس احنا كنا نعاني مثلا من
مشكله انه الاجانب كانوا يحولوا رواتبهم
الى الى دولهم وهذا امر طبيعي فبالتالي
اليوم الاثر مقارنه مع هذا الزياده
ومقارنه مع مكان سابقا يعني في الفترات هل
في تغيير تغير سريعا
في عام 2010 كانت تحويلات الاجانب 98
مليار اليوم 143 مليار لكن خذ ببالك انه
زادوا عدد الاجانب اثنين زادت الاجور
والمرتبات للاجانب نفسهم فهذا طبيعي انه
يزيد معاك لكن المهم لما كانت تركيبه
الاقتصاد تقوم على الاقتصاد ريعي يعني
تقوم على معونات ومساعدات الدوله بشكل
كبير جدا كان يذهب جزء من المساعدات هذه
في هذه التحويلات والاستفاده الاجانب منها
فاليوم مع تغير الهيكله الاقتصاد اصبح من
المجدي انه عادي لو تتحول لو يبيع يعمل
الاجانب لكن في النهايه هيكل الاقتصاد
يستحمل ولا تذهب المعونات بشكل خاطئ زي ما
كانت سابقا فاليوم التعديل الاقتصادي
اعتقد انه متناسب مع الاوضاع الحاليه
اشكرك شكر جزيلا عبد الله الردي المنتدى
بالرئيس تنفيذي لشركه رسائنا الماليه شكرا
لك
رائع بعد قليل
مبادره الطريق مكه اكثر من 370 الف مستفيد
خلال سته اعوام
اهلا بكم من جديد تتوافدوا هذه الايام
بعثته الحج الى السعوديه تمهيدا لموسم حج
استثنائي مبادره طريق مكه احدى المبادرات
التي استفاد منها مئات الالاف من الحجاج
في عده دول اسلاميه شاهد المتروك مره اخرى
تعود تعرفنا على المبادره وعلى رحلتها
التي انطلقت قبل سته اعوام تقريبا
قبل سته اعوام وتحديدا في العام 2017
اطلقت وزاره الداخليه السعوديه مبادره
طريق مكه ضمن برنامج خدمه ضيوف الرحمن
التابعي لبرامج رؤيه السعوديه 2030 بهدفي
رحله حج ميسره وبجوده عاليه للحجاج
المستفيدين بدات المبادره في دوله واحده
هي ماليزيا وتوسعت لتشمل الان ثمان دول
عربيه وافريقيه واسيويه احداثها تركيا
التي انضمت امس الى الدول المستفيده ووصلت
اولى رحلات الحجاج الاتراك الى مطار
المدينه المنوره ضمن المبادره المبادره
تعمل على انهاء اجراءات الضيوف الرحمن من
بلدانهم بدءا من اصدار التاشيره
الالكترونيه ونقلهم الى اقامتهم وانهاء
اجراءات الجوازات في مطار بلد المغادره
ونقلهم الى مقرئ اقامتهم في المشاعر
المقدسه عبر مسارات مخصصه واستفاد من
المبادره حتى الان اكثر من
376 الف حاج طوال الاعوام السابقه وزير
الخارجيه الماليزي وصف مبادره طريق مكه
بانها فكره ونهج ابداعي تنفذه السعوديه
لتسهيل رحله الحجاج معربا عن سعادته
باستفاده الحجاج الماليزيين من هذه
المبادره
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض ينضم الينا
المهندس محمد ابو الخير اسماعيل رئيس
تنفيذي لبرنامج خدمه ضيوف الرحمن مبادره
طريق مكه ايضا حياك الله معي مهندس
اسماعيل حياكم الله اليوم المبادره تعود
بصوره مختلفه
ستعود ارقام الحجاج لوضعها الطبيعي ما قبل
الجائحه فبالتالي كيف يتم التعامل الان من
خلال هذه المبادره مع هذه العوده بدايه
اشكركم على الاستضافه
واحب ارفع التهنئه الى القياده الرشيده
الحمد لله الاخبار الجميله تتوارى
تتوالى عفوا من استقبال الحجاج الى عوده
رواد الفضاء السعوديين بفضل الله وحمده
بسلامه الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وكذلك الاخبار الطيبه عندكم في القناه
قناه العربيه الجميله الجوائز
فلا يسعني الا انك كذلك اني وجهه لكم الله
يعطيكم العافيه ما يخفى عليك اخي خالد
وعلى الساده المشاهدين بفضل الله تعالى
عادت الحجاج هذا العام الى سابق عهدها
الان مبادره طريق مكه تحقق بفضل الله نجاح
متتالي منذ اطلاقها
اليوم بامر الله تعالى نحقق ونطبق هذه
المبادره في سبع دول مختلفه ودولتين
اضافيه هي جمهوريه تركيا وكذلك جمهوريه
ساحل العاج اذا نظرنا الى هذه المبادره
دائما نعمل في منظومه الحج والعمره بتكادف
جميع الجهات ذات العلاقه في ان نحلل كل
مراحل رحله ضيف الرحمن ونسال نفسنا السؤال
المهم هل نحتاج الى هذا الاجراء اذا كنا
نحتاج هذا الاجراء كيف يمكن ان نطور هذا
الاجرام وهذا هو المقصد من وراء مبادره
طريق مكه التي حقيقه تتكاتف بالنسبه لي
تعتبر مجال للابداع وكذلك مجال للتعاون
الكبير ما بين كل اصحاب المصلحه في هذه
المبادره واللي تزيد عن سبع جهات حكوميه
مختلفه تعمل بشكل متكاتف نعمل في هذه
المبادره على انهاء كافه الاجراءات منذ
بلد الضيف بحيث انه يصل ضيف الرحمن الحاج
الى المطار وينتقل مباشره من باب الطائره
الى باب الحافله الى مقر سكنه ويجد كذلك
امتعه جاهزه في مقر السكن
توسع كبير وزياده في الاعداد عام بعد عام
وان شاء الله تعالى كذلك يكون مستقبلها
النجاح والتوسع
السؤال الحاج يمكن ما تغير لكن اليوم بعد
المبادره كيف تتعاملوا في الاجابه على
اسئلتهم الفائده اللي انا حاخذها من بعد
الانضمام او انضمام دولتي الى هذه
المبادره لاجراءات كيف ممكن تيسر او تسهل
وصولا الى الى اداء المناسك وعوده كذلك
الى بلاده بالنسبه لنا المعيار الاساسي في
هذا الموضوع هو تجربه الحاج ومستوى رضا
الحاج نعمل من خلال مع شركائنا في منظومه
خدمه ضيوف الرحمن على قياس مدى رضا الحجاج
عن هذه الامور وعن جميع مراحل تجربتهم منذ
ان ينتووا القدوم الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه سواء الاداء الحج والعمره وحتى
يعود سالمين عوده على النقطه اللي تفضلت
فيها تحديدا
الحاج يهم ان يؤدي نسكه وان يحصل على ارق
الخدمات وكذلك ان يتجاوز كافه الاجراءات
وفق افضل الممارسات العالميه وهذا ما تحقق
هذه المبادره لا يضطر الى الانتظار ابدا
بكل يسر وسهوله وتنتهي كافه اجراءاته من
بلده فيصل ويتجاوز كافه الاجراءات وينتقل
في ثلاثه شديده جدا فهي تعتبر اضافه عاليه
بالنسبه له اذا المعيار الفني هنا هو وقت
الانتظار الذي
لا يحسب بحكم انه لا يقف اصلا في مراحل
القدوم
عندنا بس سبع دول انضمت الى هذه المبادره
من 57 دوله اسلاميه دوله واحده عربيه من
22 هي عدد الدول العربيه لما تشوف ان
وتيره انضمام هذه الدول بطيئه او بطيئه
جدا
يعني خلال هذه الفتره مش المفروض مثلا يوم
نتكلم عنها كل شيء ثلاث كل سنه مثلا نقول
18 20 دوله ولا انا مستعجل زياده عن
اللزوم صحيح لكن يجب ان نتذكر كذلك انه
العمل الماضي اعاده اعداد الحجاج بما
يقارب كان عدد الحجاج فقط مليون حاج وكذلك
استمرت هذه المبادره وخدمت مجموعه من
الحجاج اذا ما كنت واهم خمسه دول خلال
العام الماضي
ويعني جائحه كورونا لا اعادها الله
توقف قدوم الحجاج من خارج المملكه على مدى
سنتين
بشكل دقيق نقدر نقول انه هذه ممكن تكون
رابع سنه لهذه المبادره وزياده جيده وكذلك
احب اركز كذلك على الدول الموجوده ذات
كثافات سكانيه كبيره وتخدم اعداد كبيره من
الحجاج فالمساله كذلك تحتاج اننا ننظر لها
من جوانب مختلفه من ناحيه الاستقبال من
الدول او في مراسلات تجيكم او طلبات من
دول للانضمام بطبيعه الحال
لكل كل دوله تسعى الى توفير
الخدمات هذه الاضافيه الى حجاجها وكذلك
الزملاء حقيقه ان قاده هذه المبادره
زملائنا في وزاره الداخليه لا يتوانى عن
تقديم هذه الخدمات ابدا للجميع
واحب حقيقه هنا اكرس او اركز على شكر كافه
الجهات التي تعمل في هذه المنظومه بقياده
وزاره الداخليه ان كان وزاره الصحه لا
اريد ان اذكر الجهات سواء كان وزاره الصحه
او وزاره الحج والعمره
هيئه البيانات الطيران المدني الزكاه
والضريبه والجميع حقيقه انا كنت ما بدي
اذكر بعض الجهات حتى لا انسى البعض لانه
الحمد لله عمل تكاملي جميل يعكس انصهار
كافه جهات المملكه العربيه السعوديه
التكاليف الحج بالنسبه للحاج مع المبادره
هذه تقلت في وضعها ولا زادت ولا كيف
بالنسبه
للملهى علاقه في خليني اقول هنا انه هي
تتعلق بتيسير الاجراءات اكثر ولكن دائما
ما تضمن المملكه العربيه السعوديه وصول
الحجاج
تكاليف
متوفره لدى الجميع وتقدم لهم افضل الخدمات
على كافه مراحل الرحله انا اشكر جزيل
الشكر جزيل تمنياتنا لكم بالتوفيق شكرا
جزيلا لك دائما تتواجد معنا مهندس محمد
ابو الخير اسماعيل الرئيس التنفيذي
لبرنامج شكرا لكم شكرا لكم على الاستضافه
وشكرا الله يحييك
حضور كبير لفيلم كاندهار على شاشات
السينما العالميه وهو اول فيلم عالمي تم
تصويره وتنفيذه في السعوديه تحديدا في
محافظه العلا الفيلم من بطوله ايجار باتلر
ودع عرضه في الصلاه منذ الخميس الماضي
يحكي الصراع الاستخباراتي بين الاجهزه
الامريكيه والبريطانيه والايرانيه
والباكستانيه ويتناول وقائع حديثه منها
تفجير معمل نتانز في ايران واغتيال المشرف
على البرنامج النووي الايراني لفخري زاد
غيرها
وانضم الينا من ولايه مينا الامريكيه
المنتج فيلم
قندهار المصور في العلا كيف تقيمها واين
تضعف بين الافلام التي انتجها اسكت
لاستيتي
كانت رائعه في في تصوير الفيلم بالعلب
ثمانيه اشهر في السعوديه كان وقت
جميل واستمتعتوا
كان تحديا
من الافلام لكننا حصلنا على دعم كبير من
هيئه مختلفه حكوميه اتت لمساعدتنا وكانت
تجربتنا رائعه
بالنظر الى ما خرجنا به كفيلم فا نحن
سعداء بما انتجناه
واجهه مفاجات وكانت تجربتي فعلا جميله جدا
بتصوير الفيلم هناك
التسهيلات والدعم الانتاجيه المطلوبه
لتوفرت لك في العلا سيد اسكت لاستيتي
من الامور التي استمتعت بها كثيرا وكذلك
مساعدي هو في البدايه
تصوير الفيلم في السعوديه كان
ليس في الفتره التي كنا فيها بل هناك
تسهيلات وموارد
وكنا بحاجه الى فريق ذو خبرك
اعجبتني يا حقيقه اننا هناك اقلنا شراكه
مع شركائنا السعوديين وخرجنا بشيء جديد
لم تكن هناك كثير من التسهيلات في العلا
لكن الان هناك يبنون حاليا
مسرح صوت لكن في وقت تصوير الفيلم لم يكن
هناك شيء
استخدمنا موقع وهو بيت صغير
استخدمناه
وساعدونا في وهي الهيئه الملكيه التي
ساعدتنا في تصوير الفيلم وبعض المعدات
التي لم تكن موجوده لكن هذا لكنها الان
اصبحت موجوده كنا بحاجه لدعم لمساعده
للندخل المعدات والكوادر وحتى الطاقم وكان
من المهم ان نرى هذا الحماسه
شاهدناه من الكوادر التي انضمت انضمت
للعمل معنا كثير منهم خبره وكثر لم يكن
لديهم الخبره بل تعلموا معنا كانت رحله
جيده في العلا ساعدنا بها وكسبنا خبره
ويسرنا ان نقوم بهذه التجربه مره ثانيه
وكانت
تجربه مثيره وانا لدي فعلا لهف ان اقوم
بالتصوير مره ثانيه هناك
هل هناك اتفاق على فيلم على مسلسل او على
عمل في العلا قادم مستقبلي
سيشن
هناك حوار حالي
ليس لدي شيء محدد لكن هناك نقاش
وانا احب السعوديه واود ان اعود لصناعه
فيلم جديد هذا هدف لي هناك لنقاش لا
استطيع التحدث عن فيلم محدد لكن هناك نقاش
يدور الان حول افلام قادمه وهدفي هو
العوده والتصوير
لمزيد من الافلام في السعوديه
كمنتج لك خبره في الافلام السينمائيه لك
عده اعمال معروفه ايضا السيد
وهو ايضا واحد من اهم الاسماء في عالم
السينما ايضا الامريكيه
كيف تنظر الى السعوديه اليوم كواحد من
المناطق
واول العلا ايضا في صناعه الافلام في
صناعه السينما العالميه اين يمكن ان تقع
ان تضعها يعني
للغايات اعتقد ان السعوديه مؤهله جدا لان
تكون
مقصد الاول لصناعه الافلام في المنطقه
اولا لان هناك محفزات تقدم من الدوله
للافلام للافلام الجيده
والمحفزات
لصناعه الافلام جيده في العالم لكنها في
السعوديه منافسه جدا وافضل من اي محفزات
اخرى في اي مكان اخر لذلك هذا امر يستقدم
صانع الافلام
وامر ثاني وهو
تنوع البيئه في السعوديه
بشكل المنطقه في العلا قلاب جدا وكذلك
يمكن بناء المواقع مواقع التصوير بشكل
مختلف وبشكل متنو
وبالتالي فهي ليست مساله
لتقييم العلا لشكلها فقط بل يمكن ان تصنع
هذه الاشكال على مواقع التصوير
صورنا ايضا في جده وهي مدينه حيويه ويمكن
هذا ان
يضاف للمواقع التصوير ارى مستقبلا لتصوير
الافلام في السعوديه وهناك امور ذكيه تتم
الان وهناك
منتجين اذكياء محليين يقومون ببناء هذه
القاعده لصناعه الافلام بوسعي القول ان
المنطقه ستصبح بتاكيد مقصدا لصناعه
الافلام وانا مهتم بان اشاهد كيف ستتطور
هذه
الصناعه في السعوديه وكما رقبتها في انحاء
اخرى في العالم
على السعوديه لتضع
نفسها في خارطه الانتاج السينمائي العالمي
دعني يعني اسالك عن الفيلم من ناحيه فنيه
نقديه وهنا ربما يستعرض لك جزء من مقاله
هي ناقده دراميه رئيسيه في نيويورك تايمز
تحدثت وقالت بان وصفت هذا الفيلم بانه
فيلم ممل فيلم بطيء بشكل مذهل فهذه في
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
وان بيتلر في هذا الفيلم اختار وسيره غير
فعاله القصه غير متماسكه دراميا احد
النقاد العرب يقول مثلا بانه هذا الفيلم
ليس فيه جديد باظهار رجل الاستخبارات
الامريكيه الرجل الخارق للعاده الذي يعني
تتنافس عليه الكثير من الدول للامساك به
كما حصل في قندهار ولكنها لم تفلح مثل هذه
الرؤى النقديه
يعني الى اي مدى تؤثر في الفيلم وخاصه في
الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في قبولا وعدم قبول هذا هذا
الفيلم
الوقت في حليف هو الكفيل عفوا بان يخبرنا
هذه الاجابه واعتقد انه بكل فيلم نراه
سيكون هناك نقاد من كلا الطرفين من يعجبهم
من لا يعجبهم هذا النقد الذي ذكرته انا
سمعته وانهم كانوا يتوقعون من الفيلم ان
يكون عباره عن اكشن مستمر
لا يتوقف لكن ان اردنا عمقا بالفيلم لن
تكون هناك حركه طوال الوقت
المساله في صناعه الافلام ان هناك دائما
من
يعجبهم ومن لا يعجبهم هذا امر طبيعي شكرا
جزيلا لك
منتج فيلم
من ولايه من الامريكيه
وصلت الطائره التي تقل راي ايديه الفضاء
السعوديين على القرني وريان البرناوي له
في ولايه تكساس الامريكيه بعد انتهاء
رحلتهما التاريخيه الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه ويحمل رايداء الفضاء 92 عينه من
التجارب العلميه التي تضمنتها المهمه في
اول شهور يونيو مربعانيه وفي منتصفه ينتهي
موسم هطول الامطار خالد
[موسيقى]
الشهر السادس من شهور السنه الميلاديه
يسمى بيونيو ويونيو احد الاربعه شهور الذي
يتكون من ثلاثين يوما يسمى بالعراق وبلاد
الشام بحزيران والمغرب العربي يسمونه
بجوان ومصر يسمونه ديون واصل التسميه
ماخوذه من جون وهي زوجه الهه السماء
الروماني جوبيتر والذي يحب زوجته كثيرا
اني احبك حبا لو علمت به لازهر الكون في
عينيك
وازدهر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وشهر يونيو في اوله تبدا مربعانيه القيل
وهي الاربعين يوما السابقه على الحر
اللاهب والمسماه عند العامه بزاد
وفي منتصفه ينتهي الموسم الطبيعي لنزول
الامطار على بلدان الخليج ما عدا سلطنه
عمان واليمن وجنوب السعوديه فهذه تبدا
عندهم موسم الامطار الخريفيه وفي نهايته
نعيش اطول نهر واقصر ليالي السنه وترد
الشمس بارحه الى الجهه الجنوبيه البارحه
يا حبيبي ضاقي صدري والقلب حزن على فرقه
حبيبه يا من يرد الحبيب وياخذ اجري قفا
بلا سبه
ربي حسيبه
[موسيقى]
العناوي
الجيش السوداني يعلق اتفاقيه جده وتجدد
القصف المدفعي في شمال ام درمان بالخرطوم
بعد ثمانيه اعوام السعوديه تكشف عن
تعدادها الجديد 32 مليون مواطن ومقيم
شباب يتصدرون التعداد السعوديين الحديث 63
في المئه من اجمالي المواطنين ذكورا
واناثا
رائد الفضاء ريان وعلي يصلن هيوستن بعد
عوده سالمه الى الارض ويخضعان لحجر صحي
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات